[Music]
salmon sushi is in Japanese it's
Norwegian huh okay here's the story
until about 1995 raw salmon was not
consumed in Japan and this was for one
big reason Pacific salmon has parasites
oh so no salmon sushi sashimi no spicy
salmon nothing what but obviously that
all changed thanks in part to this guy
Norway had a problem they had a lot of
salmon and too small a market looking
east they set their sights on Japan a
country that loves raw fish so much it's
willing to pay five times the price for
sushi grade so Noor we formed a
committee and hired bjorn from 1986 to
1991 I worked for okay their job was to
convince Japanese consumers that
Atlantic salmon was safe to consume raw
and this was hard just take for example
pork if some guy from Norway came here
and said here
er pork meat raw it's safe it's really
yummy we'd be like man you're crazy it
was basically American perception so we
had to change the whole country Buuren
and his team got to work they made the
first ever salmon rolls and serve them
to businessmen in Japan which they
didn't like for a long time it took
actually 10 years ok I get the proper
breakthrough in the market so there it
is salmon sushi didn't exist before 1995
Bjorn on behalf of the world we thank
you
[Music]
Chinese takeout that convenient hunger
buster that can turn up at your door
within minutes and a perfectly packaged
Chinese takeout box funny thing about
that Chinese takeout box it's actually
American yeah although the box's folds
in style were inspired by Japanese
origami the packaging is a uniquely
Western invention in 1894 chicago-based
inventor Frederic weeks Wilcox patented
the paper pail a single piece of paper
folded into a leak-proof container
fastened with a wire handle around this
time California experienced a huge
influx of Chinese immigrants many came
here in search of gold bringing along
their cuisine and culture fast forward
to the post-war boom every family is
moving to the idyllic suburbs
conveniences paramount and Chinese
takeout starts to take off then in the
1970s a graphic designer
added a pagoda to the side of the box
along with a faux Asian thank you on top
from then on the containers became a
fixture of the Chinese takeout industry
even though they have never been used in
China
[Music]
this is the aluminum ball challenge we
are doing the aluminum foil ball
challenge it swept the Internet it was
pretty much people making smooth shiny
balls out of aluminum foil it originated
in Japan but the story doesn't end there
it gets more meta because this challenge
actually came from another tradition in
Japan and in true Japanese fashion that
tradition is pretty spectacular
Dola dango is a Japanese art form in
which earth and water are molded to
create a delicate shiny sphere that's a
nice way of saying that these are very
fancy mud balls and when it comes to
making dollar dango in Japan Kyoko Miki
is one of the best the Rodin Mottola
Naruto danmaku mia vicentico Devadas
Julian Anka Donald are not so good your
stylist donaga Carlito you know needs to
go could cure me on my step
toda movin induced no didn't occur Deva
Katta Morocco Tokido Kino de Mendoza not
chica Arriba - good morrow medic at
America Durga dekimasu the process
condensed goes like this
get a clay based mud mix it with hay
this helps keep it from falling apart
roll it into a sphere and leave it to
dry in the Sun no denotes gurus Iike a
kamikaze chicken re masa know they
collide assume alpha at ova Amina khuda
ke - Terra Mystica haha Reba Miki Matsu
anoche oughta take a kiss take a guy
take a single mother minute a good uncle
Cato died today
curry - Tata - Desna
and the story doesn't end here because
where there is something beautiful there
is a competition to prove who is the
best in Kyoko is a judge this is the
annual dollar dango tournament into
Konami Japan card automatic I know since
our into hajima chi-chi Makara okana
taurima's Toshi they do it in a mini
Nagamasa a camino de rue de novo poco
poco de un acto de mayo cart and SK Domo
nakai Makarova tengo una cute is ava
Moore hobo de campeche Nina taurima's no
day at OVA a no hero not sky cata minguk
attached our egoic 300 juicy story
myself my toast icon akuto so noticed so
notice it a Johanna I know can Doga
umareta keymaster this year contestants
from all over Japan have come to
showcase their work
it looks like they've got a winner so
what does a winning Dola dango look like
very shiny any kind me put them Rudy see
this colored plain large small the Dola
dango is not a one look pony it
exemplifies so much of Japanese culture
patience perfection and the pursuit of
beauty and everyday things and they're
also pretty cool to look at let me check
on that
[Music]
it's called a clowder of cats
if you have a question any question
there's a number you can call 911
275 697 five and a librarian at the New
York Public Library will try to answer
it for you
hello thanks for calling ask and ypl we
have ten librarians on a team and we
answer any question that you may have
over the telephone in the office today
we have Matthew Barnard Sarina
Diane and me our department asked NYPL
began in 1967 we started answering
questions over the telephone but people
have been reaching out to librarians for
as long as there have been libraries the
New York Public Library has actually
saved records of some of the more
interesting questions they've been asked
over the years like is there a full moon
every night in Acapulco why do 18th
century English paintings have so many
squirrels in them and how did they
obtain them so they wouldn't fight the
painter or Plato Aristotle and Socrates
one in the same person in a world of
Google it's a bit surprising to know
that they get around 30,000 calls per
year my question is why oftentimes
people might not have access to the
technology at home and I honestly think
some just want somebody to talk to so
the next time you have a question like
how many teeth does a great white shark
have you can call this number nine one
seven two seven five six nine seven five
that will ring inside of this building
up on this floor and maybe Barnard or
Rosa will pick up and they'll answer it
for you
they have about 300 serrated teeth
ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the American flag has endured in its
many forms as the ultimate symbol of
freedom justice in the American Way but
did you know that our nation's flag was
designed by a high school student from
Ohio according to legend the original
American flag from 1776 was sewn by a
lady named Betsy Ross it had 13 stars in
a circle representing America's original
13 States as more states joined the
Union people kept adding more stars to
the flag
so by 1958 the US flag had a total of 48
stars for the 48 states of that time
which brings us to our high school
student Robert heft Roberts history
teacher gave his students and open-ended
assignment make a project illustrating
your interest in American history it
could be anything so Robert who was
jazzed about hearing that Alaska and
Hawaii were going to become States cut
up an old 48 state flag and his
grandparents basement and designed his
own vision for a 50 state flag
when he turned in his final assignment
robert's teacher said anyone can make a
flag and it's got the wrong number of
stars the grade came back a b-minus
Robert tried to explain his idea to his
teacher who replied I'll change your
gray when your flag is accepted by the
US Congress game on Robert wrote 21
letters and called the White House 18
times until one day in 1960 Roberts
phone rang it was President Eisenhower
with news that Roberts 50-state flag
design had actually been chosen as the
new official flag of the United States
the president invited Roberts Washington
where he saw his American flag flied for
the first time on July 4th nineteen
sixty cents then Roberts 50-state flag
has remained unmatched is the
quintessential symbol of America but I
know what you're thinking whatever
happened to that B - Roberts teacher
honored his promise and changed the
grade to an A
[Music]
you
[Music]
we're all familiar with coca-cola but
this is also Coke it said that clear
coke was a top-secret project made
exclusively for a thirsty red Russian
[Music]
during World War two coca-cola made a
global splash boosting American troops
morale at one point
Dwight D Eisenhower met with Georgy
Zhukov a Soviet General instrumental in
the defeat of Nazi Germany Eisenhower
introduced him to coke try this Zhukov
was hooked but after the war Koch was
seen as a symbol of American imperialism
and was banned from the Soviet Union
yeah no not here so Zhukov called up
none other than US President Harry
Truman to send him a secret stash I'm
going to need Coca Cola
Truman agreed to help Zhukov out alright
you got it
he got the top dogs at coca-cola to
disguise its iconic look they eliminated
the drinks artificial coloring but made
sure the new vodka look-alike still had
that classic coke taste they packaged it
in street glass bottles capped with a
red star according to a World War 2 coke
wrap 50 cases were sent to Russia
Zhukov got his fix he was never caught
with the disguised Cola and as far as we
know it hasn't been sip since